-More with Michael Keaton
when we come back.
♪♪
Do you mind? I'll do a couple
promos saying that you're here.
You can put that there.
I'm just gonna --
You don't have to do anything.
-Really?
-Yeah.
These are just commercials.
-I'm willing to do something.
-This one is...
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ] All right.
What do we do?
We go, uh...
-Look at all the toys
you have back there,
all the stuff you have.
-There's not really
that many great things.
There's, like,
a lot of Purell and...
Uh, how about I say, like,
"We have a great show,"
and then I go,
"You wanna squirt?"
-Sure.
-And we'll end it on
"Wanna squirt?"
-Yeah, okay. Wait. It has to end
on "Wanna squirt?"
-Yeah. Do you want to say it?
-By the way, does it --
I hope it means
"Would you like a squirt?"
as opposed to
"Do you want to squirt?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I never got to that question,
did I? Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Hi, Scott. Hi, Anne-Marie.
Michael Keaton is here tonight.
Michael Keaton!
Plus we have Heidi Klum
and an in-studio performance
from Vince Staples
featuring Fousheé.
Is there something
you would like to ask?
-Do you want a squirt?
-Sure.
-Okay.
-Back to you guys.
This is our last one here?
This one's generic.
This one could be --
All right.
What should this one be?
Maybe I'll do this one boozy?
-Okay.
-All right. Ready?
[Slurring] Hey, everyone.
Michael Keaton is here tonight.
Plus we have Heidi Klum...
[Hiccups]
...and an in-studio
performance --
Do you like that hiccup?
[Normal voice] From Vince
Staples featuring Fousheé
tonight! [Hiccups]
That was the old way to act.
-Drunk's hard to do.